you see that [ __ ] [ __ ] on [ __ ]
online yeah
so great so crazy man what do you think
about this oh my God what whoa what the
hell was that guys well Bryce what's up
well calm down what's up cologne Bryce
I'm trying to take a piss I don't have a
dick
what what are you say I don't have a
dick okay we're live we're live show it
what do you mean you don't have a dick I
went to go pee I don't have a penis and
I'm scared I don't I don't know where it
is what what are you talking about no
dick what what no [ __ ] I don't have a
[ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is my dick well you know
I I didn't do anything with the dick I
[ __ ] with my dick you [ __ ] my dick I
didn't know anything you know the
cloning process is not very no cake
relax relax you know I'm sure it's
around here somewhere somewhere it's
probably around here somewhere dude
we're gonna be okay we're gonna be okay
dude just just sit down okay we'll just
be around yourself yeah it'll it'll turn
up it'll turn up we're gonna find your
dick bro hey man we're not gonna stiff
you okay we'll find your dick yeah is
that a dick joke
no it can't be hard to find it yeah
that was also a dick joke
I don't have a dick don't worry about it
dude it's okay it's fine we're gonna
find it we'll find it It's gotta be it's
definitely around here somewhere it's at
the top of my head yeah just exactly so
it's it's there somewhere yeah I feel
like it's right
in front of our noses you know yeah
behind our noses or something yeah you
guys mess up a dick no it's we'll figure
it out anyways everybody down to stick
around though and just kind of chill
I'll chill for a little bit okay
great no this is great everybody
um we already had a guest plan but I
guess we have two our first guest is
Bryce Hall and our second Bryce yeah
clone Bryce let's be very clear yeah we
had a second guest today very special
guy
um socialist Jesus yeah whatever you
want to call him um it's Hassan
everybody makes a noise for some sound
like get in here
he's even bigger in person oh my God oh
my Lord now first thing I have to make a
note of here is that you ordered cold
brew I did for the people on the ship
yeah I did and so you got that one for
yourself right there can you hold that
up hold that up it's crazy that they
delivered to the spaceship is wild but
why did you get me this one
I okay
it's like a tall there's like there's
like four more of those in there because
I felt bad ordering just like one
Starbucks to a [ __ ] spaceship you
know what I mean yeah so I was like I'll
just get like I'll just
rapidly click that I guess I didn't get
like a adequate size why does that one
say Cody on it
it says Cody's special kid size yeah
that's what is it that's weird anyway
yeah I got a bunch
um I ordered a bunch because I was
waiting for you guys you just you just
say one Starbucks yeah yeah like a
singular Starbucks what's up man I'm a
song Hey Bryce nice to meet you I guess
I wasn't enough I wasn't clouded enough
that you were like yo let's bring some
[ __ ] Tick Tock numbers in here that's
crazy the disrespect is so surreal to me
currently I've known both of these
[ __ ] for like 10 years now okay
they walked in late 30 minutes late five
minutes late 10 minutes he's like 10
minutes late I'll own it I was 30
minutes late yeah he's 30 minutes late
he's 10 minutes late I'm late because
he's late every time yeah he walked
there he's like oh [ __ ] you guys and
then immediately beams towards this guy
he's like oh my God what a pleasure no
no no no no no let's be clear I said
dream come true yeah he's a dream come
I'm true I'm like dream come true are
you [ __ ] joking like what am I doing
here the disrespect is mutual all right
yeah [ __ ] you all right let's get a
couple things out of the way first of
all that's for calling me a [ __ ] on
leftovers okay that's that's number one
wait what did he say he's just like he
was like it's probably true though yeah
he said invite me on the podcast you
[ __ ] I was like oh oh I had people just
messaging me yo whose song called you a
[ __ ] I'm like not on my watch yeah you
do you do look like like a UFC fighter
more every day thank you dude yeah yeah
both of you guys are looking really are
you guys on his plan like what's
happening
I did one boxing match I just did I just
did one no but you lift like crazy don't
you not really do you not I mean I like
every picture I see of you on Twitter is
you like post it up in the gym like
posing well yeah I mean like that wasn't
working mid Journey yeah Bryce just uses
AI art he's like I got to make some
content yeah me lifting extremely heavy
and then he puts that [ __ ] out in the
world I I brought you guys gifts did you
I did yeah you did it well it's not
really that big of a get I didn't get
you anything
that's not that big of a gift
[ __ ]
no what is that okay first of all I have
often I I have been a long time
supporter of short King no yeah okay you
have I I've I've rode for you guys no I
I went to Porsche earlier to get my car
don't you feel don't you feel jealous
right now I feel like a piece of [ __ ]
yeah I feel like a [ __ ] I got one
for you too ah there you go
how's it taste dude oh it tastes German
um
that's not Porsche water that's Porsche
water yeah truly man yeah it's not even
that good it's really not I was at the I
was tap water they they took my uh yeah
they took my car back there's like a
bunch of recalls or some [ __ ] and I
hadn't had it for like weeks so I was
like oh this is perfect I'll go grab it
and then I saw that and I was like this
is they will appreciate this Porsche
water yeah well this is so kind of you
to bring to us yeah yeah what did you
guys get me nothing oh what are you
talking about we gotta use screen time
yeah those thank you we got you exposure
now we have to [ __ ] share it with us
yeah we got you Bryce you've always
[ __ ] hauling the flesh yeah how many
podcast guests give you gifts though
yeah
um I mean Brian J Alvarez cut us each
like a half a bar of gold so
just straight up what the [ __ ] yeah okay
I can't perform like that I'm joking I'm
joking yeah
Zack and Wally brought us custom jackets
yeah Letterman Jack that was sick so
this is like that's a normal thing it's
a normal thing for guests I guess yeah
I'm so undermined right now what is
happening because you have it's because
your water sucks bro I don't know we're
trending every day on Twitter yeah I
made it a point in my mind I'm like
today I'm gonna make a son feel regular
that's it yeah that's I love that but
when I'm training every day on Twitter
it's like it's literally nothing I did
yeah it's always like people just either
making [ __ ] up or just like
misunderstanding or assuming that I'm
involved in some other [ __ ] that I'm not
involved in yeah I think people just
find out you have a car every couple
weeks no that's why I brought the porch
water so I could get trending again
what's this episode Hassan has a Porsche
[ __ ] yeah it's crazy it all
started when you know I bought the house
yeah and then it was just like Hassan
bought a house drama every single time
which yeah you were gonna give them [ __ ]
for that right yeah it was I told you
how to hide your address I did it oh
yeah exactly no you did and I did all of
that oh and it's still [ __ ] leaked oh
okay yeah so how do they do how do they
figure out dude I don't know I think
they got like someone uh you know
they're like bribing someone at like the
county office or something like that's
creepy yeah I don't know they just they
were real hard dude it's crazy what is
your address yes let me tell you okay
um
but you know it was it was not great
when that happened but it is what it is
yeah someone someone called me a simp
for shouting you out on the Cutie
episode
yeah they were like [ __ ] Noel is
always calling out Hassan what a simp
what do you have never called me out uh
maybe like twice on the show no but it's
like in a friendly way yeah that is
pretty it's like we're friends you're
you're like a simpy way yeah like a
friendly
no I think like I think the pandemic
broke people's brains so like they only
know like normal human interaction
through internet terms you know what I
mean what's up dude you're simping yeah
simply for your boys yeah yeah that's
weird that's sauce bro yeah it's pretty
sauce caught you in 4k man like damn